um gewalt macht und sex geht es auch in
der neuverfilmung von alfred döblins
klassiker berlin alexanderplatz von
burhan qurbani was ist das ein paar
kleidungsstücke
ich mag noch nicht
nein
die scheiß masken
das ist eine neuverfilmung die radikal
versuch den stoff dieses also 29
veröffentlichten romans in berlin der
gegenwart zu transportieren
die hauptperson franz wird hier
umgeschrieben der hintergrund wohl
umgeschrieben nämlich zu einem
migrationshintergrund gemacht
es ist franks es aus piesau der uns hier
begegnet als hauptperson ein immigrant
der den weg über das meer mittelmeer
geschafft hat in berlin strandet und
dort in die fänge eines gangsters eines
klein gangsters gerät mit namen reinhold
franz ist ein aufpasser damit wachse
schwester team das schon ich musste
durch anritzen dörfer dieser
psychotische charakter reinhold
fantastisch gespielt von albrecht fängt
einen sofort ein in diesem 10
die art wie er auftritt mit einer ganz
bestimmten versehrtheit körperlich und
vor allem in psychischer versehrtheit
einer unberechenbarkeit und und und und
innere zerrüttung die lässt ein sofort
den blick auf ihn wenden
sutil blog sony music und wenn ich mir
wie gehen wir ihnen gefällt nicht so da
was richtig und in dieser in diesem
zusammenspiel zwischen reinholz und
franz der uns mit franks heißt wenn
umgetauft wird und der auch fantastisch
gespielt wird von der ecke bonk
das ist eigentlich die spannung die
diesen film am anfang aus macht der der
junge starke immigrant der den deutschen
traum sich erfüllen will trifft auf
diesen psychisch zerrütteten
drogendealer und hilft ihm dann in
verschiedener hinsicht organisiert das
drogengeschäft in der hasenheide für ihn
geht mit ihm feiern nimmt ihm die frauen
ab denn diesen reinhold treibt eine
schreckliche trieb störung um er
verlangt nach frauen aber in dem moment
wo er sie hat mit ihnen schläft ekel sie
und da hilft ihm franzis drei gorilla
boku kannst du bist ein gorilla besser
erziehen
da kann ich nicht einfach reden angreift
ich bin kein buch aspekten ist das geht
alles einigermaßen gut bis zu dem moment
wo reinhold in einem sadistischen schub
den franz aus dem aus einem fahrenden
auto hinaus stößt und ihn schwer
verletzt zurück lässt
das ist ein schock in diesem film der
auch gleichzeitig ein umschlag punkt
markiert ab dem moment nämlich wert wird
die bildsprache und die ganze art der
erzählweise etwas bemüht und ich würde
fast sagen kunstgewerbliche was am
anfang stark ist sozusagen diese zwei
außenseiter in der gesellschaft der
kriminelle drogenboss psychisch gestörte
und der immigrant die sich irgendwie
zusammenfinden und ein team bilden auf
einer ganz bestimmten art und weise
diese spannung wird aufgebrochen weil
nämlich franz ist bekanntermaßen so bei
der ligna vorgegeben auf mieze trifft
mieze eine edel-prostituierte kannst
wenn es ihm kommen wird 1000 euro für
eine nacht mehr rezepte nach irgendwas
eine kette winschuh tasche jahr 2000
euro für gas muss die beiden verlieben
sich und beginnen hier sogar wirklich
ein traum von familie zu träumen mieze
wird wird schwanger und eine ganze zeit
tritt reinhold aus diesem film heraus
und damit wird der film eben auch einen
ganz bestimmten hat einen ganz
bestimmten spannungs verlust erleidet er
obwohl vize gespielt wird von jella
haase die ausfahrt goethe bekannt
jugend jugendschwarm und die das auch
wirklich sehr gut macht diese
leichtfertige art des berliner 2020
gefühls irgendwie gut ausdrücken
der film ist zu lang es dauert alles
wirklich viel zu lange über drei stunden
geht er und verliert gegen ende hin
jegliche jeglichen formen will
das problem des films er will
transportieren er will alles in die
gegenwart holen bleibt aber in der
ganzen handlungs situation und vor allem
auch in der in der sprache häufig dann
doch beide blieben jedenfalls kommen
immer wieder zitate werden eingeflochten
unnatürlich diese montagetechnik des
romans auch irgendwie zu spiegeln das
geht eben nur eine ganz bestimmte zeit
lang gut und dann verliert es sich in
einer in einer belanglosen und auch
spannungslosen anschauung
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen in der frieze
das ende dann das verläuft sich und es
schafft der film schaffte es nicht bis
zum ende die spannung aufzuheben und
wird dann doch am ende zu einem
fernsehfilm in dem man eher im fernsehen
erwartet als bei der berlinale im kino
und doch schon alleine für die beiden
hauptdarsteller also und lege pinguin
ist lohnt sich dieser film hat einen
ganz bestimmten eine ganz wichtige sowie
steve kraft mehr ausgestrahlt
das ist das schlimmste das ist viel
getan hast du hörst
aber doch